japan says this summer's olympics are  going to go forward  the games were delayed last year by the  pandemic events are supposed to start in  just six  months it's not that far away fifteen  thousand athletes and support staff are  all expected to descend on tokyo in july  japan's prime minister says the nation  is prepared and determined to keep the  coronavirus at bay  officials are actually looking at using  robots to speed up testing for fans if  the fans are allowed at all  however some medical experts say moving  forward with the games could be just too  risky now we are facing with a far more  danger than last year  so why do you have to hold olympic games  much of japan is still under a state of  emergency because of the pandemic in  fact the country hasn't even approved a  vaccine yet  another big factor though to push ahead  with the world's biggest sporting event  is the cost  the government's already spent 15  billion dollars  on the facilities